hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream i am back
with dr heather heing who has regained
her ability to speak
in english is it only english at this
point it's pretty much english
limited to english all right so we have
lots to discuss this week it has not
been a boring week
um no it hasn't yeah which does raise a
question do you ever have the sense
that uh reality is gaslighting you
yeah sometimes you do get that sense
also all right
well we should talk about that because
i'm definitely i get that sense somewhat
regularly and this week it's been
particularly bad
yeah okay so you wanted to start it with
uh some commentary
i do yeah so i have i have 14 points
that i'd like to start with and i have
not shared them with you although
we have been doing plenty of talking
about what's been transpiring obviously
so please tell me this is a 14-point
plan to get us out of the trouble
it's it is not it is not but there are
there are 14 points here
um and i'm just i'm going to share them
and then we'll talk about them
okay all of these things i believe to be
true all of them
uh can be and i believe
are true one systemic racism has a long
history throughout the world
and the legacy of slavery in the u.s is
a particularly salient example
two in the u.s we were making progress
against racism both at the societal and
individual level
we weren't there we were not post-race
but we were making progress
the legacy of the civil rights era meant
that it was ever more shameful and
embarrassing to be publicly racist and
therefore more difficult to be privately
so as well
we were making progress until the last
several years when a perfect storm
arrived just two of the parts of that
perfect storm are these
one by the early to mid 2010s everyone
was carrying a camera in their pocket in
the form of smartphone
video footage of acts of police
brutality brought that violence to
everyone's living room there was now no
denying it
the flip side of this is that the
visceral anecdote
will always be more powerful than the
dispassionate statistic
so long as any grotesque incidents exist
and grotesque incidents will always
exist so long as any exist even if
police and policing improve dramatically
it will now be even more difficult to
point to the hopefulness of the second
truth
and the second of many parts of the
second of the perfect storm which have
eroded the advances of the civil rights
movement are the ascendancy of woke
culture
and intersectional thinking and critical
theory they showed up first in higher ed
spread into schools of ed from there
into k-12 schools into cubicles
journalism
media the arts and beyond this thinking
holds among
other things that we have original sin
based on the color of our skin
and that there's no escaping it point
three
black lives matter point four
the organization that has come to be
known as black lives matter does not
seem to be the upstanding honorable
organization that its tagline
would suggest
five emotion is high the reaction to
george floyd's brutal
and senseless killing was and is
emotional and that is not actually
inherently a bad thing
reason and considered analysis are not
the only ways to communicate in the
world
showing raw emotion is sharp and intense
and harsh
and hard to look away from and therefore
it can be powerful when
other modes may not be working
but six the months of lockdown which we
have
brett and i have and continue to argue
were and in some cases
may continue to be necessary for public
health made people less emotionally
emotionally resilient than they had been
before
and more fragile furthermore i believe
that seeing people in so-called red
states party over memorial day weekend
without social distancing may have
contributed to the raw emotional
outpouring by some blue state protesters
this is no justification
mind you just an observation of
factories contributing
to the mass protests that we are seeing
seven protest and the right to protest
are fundamental to democracy
eight riot is not protest
looting is not protest we have no right
to riot or to loot
and indeed rioting and looting our
anathema to democracy
nine trump is correct that antifa is
inciting violence
and that that violence is
counterproductive to having a peaceable
society
ten white nationalists may also be
involved in inciting violence
on american streets right now and trump
has in the past engaged in dog whistles
to white nationalists
furthermore his explicit mention trump's
explicit mention of the second amendment
in his mostly scripted june 1st press
conference can easily be interpreted as
a call to arms
he said quote i am mobilizing all
available federal resources civilian and
military to stop the rioting and looting
to end the destruction in arson
and to protect the rights of law-abiding
americans including your second
amendment rights
end quote what is the second amendment
doing in that sentence in particular
is it a call to civil war if this is
what it is it is beyond
anti-patriotic it may even be treason
11. some cops are racist thugs
some dentists are also racist thugs no
society
should allow racist thugs to rise to
positions of power racist thugs who are
policemen
given their job are able to do more
damage to others than are racist thugs
who are dentists or grocery clerks
garbage man or electricians
point 12 most cops are not racist thugs
most cops like most dentists and grocery
clerks and garbagemen and electricians
are honest people with an interest in
doing good
13. spreading blanket pronouncements of
the uniform
evil of some demographic such as with
the acronym a cab
all cops or bastards or the or promoting
the inherent and
unresolvable racism of all white people
is not just untrue but bad for the cause
that it is supposedly for
force good and honest people to take
loyalty oaths or make an admission of
omission of original sin where none
exists and some of those good and honest
people will become less good
and less honest others will wake up to
the hypocrisy at the core of a movement
that was supposed to do good
and wonder where to turn
finally young americans are in debt
their educations have failed them good
health care is a distant memory
the prospect of owning a house is a pipe
dream for most
many of the younger among us were raised
on legal pharmaceuticals that have
rendered us psychologically disorganized
unable to track or control their own
emotional states or to read that of
others
and our economy has become obsessed with
making us into consumers
but consumption does not provide meaning
we will find true meaning in different
ways some of us will be driven to create
some will be driven to discover some
will be driven to heal
others to communicate or to build or to
grow or synthesized
some will find meaning in the protesting
of actual injustice in the writing of
wrongs
there are so many sources of meaning to
be had instead
we are being controlled and corralled
sold to and lied to and divided
are humans deeply tribal and competitive
yeah
are humans deeply collaborative yes
let us recognize our shared humanity and
celebrate our
individual differences we can do both
we can both recognize our shared
humanity and celebrate our individual
differences
and the best leaders facilitate us doing
just that wow
i have a great joke but i can't deliver
it because that was uh
a very sober and uh
nuanced presentation so um i'm going to
resist the urge to make light of it
you're going to save the joke
no i'm saving the joke i will i'll fight
i will if i have to organize a podcast
to justify
that joke delivered at the end as a
punchline at some other point i will do
it
um but at the moment um
i just respond on mass or or go back to
individual points well there is one
point there is one point
in the interest of fairness and clarity
that i want to i don't want to say
correct because i think what you said is
technically right
but having tripped this wire last night
on twitter
i am sensitive to the hazard it implies
i have as yet seen very little evidence
of white nationalists
active at this moment in this protest
i have i have i have seen no evidence
okay but many and in fact the the thing
that i left
out here you know people are saying
is it antifa getting in the way of
legitimate protesters
is it and doing the rioting and looting
and inciting violence
is it white nationalists is it foreign
countries right i know all of these are
out there as hypotheses and at some
level
um the fact is it's divisive right so
all i want to do is make sure that we do
not leave the impression that there is
evidence for something for which we do
not have evidence so i've seen lots of
stuff that suggests
there is um unnatural behavior i don't
know if these pallets of bricks that
show up i had another conversation with
the business owner today was having
trouble sourcing bricks
something odd might be going on or not
we don't know but
all i want to say is there is no
question in my mind
that what is taking place serves those
very divisions
and may in fact lead to my biggest fear
is something
like a race war that turns into a civil
war
but as yet i have not seen the
misbehavior
that i uh might expect on the white
nationalist
side so um
make of it what you will in terms
of the rest i i'm
i think you and i have not talked about
this but i am now having conversation
after conversation where
one person after another somebody i
respect will say to me
words to the effect of um
we're all evergreen now in fact
holly mathnerd was the first person to
say something like this and what she
said was it took three years to go
um from for the country uh to reach
the evergreen stage uh after evergreen
did it
now my perspective is a little different
because we lived this
three years ago there's at least one key
difference that i see and we have not
talked about this
well there are important differences
especially uh
evergreen did not have a trump figure it
had a george bridges figure which is a
very different phenomenon
yeah um i don't know what that is from
from history but it's not trump
uh let's put it this way um
it is a lot easier to
make light of the situation when george
bridge's ineptitude is in charge rather
than
the ferocious power that any president
would have and the instincts of this
president
uh strike me as particularly dangerous
in a crisis like this but
um one one other key difference is that
um there was no
obvious instigating incident at
evergreen
there were widespread claims of racism
without
any actual incidents and
uh while we don't we may never know
everything that happened with regard to
the killing of george floyd
clearly there was an incident and it was
awful
and it was recorded and televised
so i mean i think your your 14 points do
a great job of
bringing us to this question because for
my part i'm
nervous about any single
incident triggering uh an outpouring
of anger like this because especially in
this case
you know i i don't know what reports
i've seen one report that says
that george floyd died of asphyxiation
i've seen another report that suggests
he was
saying he couldn't breathe before he was
ever on the ground and so
to the extent that you and i i think
both believe that
this protest was initially a an honest
outpouring of grief and frustration
one doesn't want to pin it obviously
this was an act of police brutality
did it kill george floyd well probably
but it you know there's at least one
scenario in which
he was dying of a heart attack was
deserving of care he didn't get because
this officer had his knee on his neck
and so yes it's a terrible incident but
if it is not exactly what it is
understood to be by the people in the
streets
does that undercut the reality of this
but then
it is also true that if it is what it
appears
that does not inherently make it a
racist act
right he could just be a white cop who
kills a black man is not inherently
doing so
because he is a racist right as i said
in the
uh the talk years ago how the magic
trick is done
you know a woman who's walking down the
street and takes me to have given her
a look that has some sort of content to
it
doesn't know whether or not that same
awkward look was given to the guy who
passed right after her
or if it was actually about her being
females you just can't tell from an
anecdote
but none of this i mean i think you and
i would agree none of this really
matters
there is honest anger and frustration
and it is really truly based on
something
even though the data on police
killings of black people are
not reflective of the pattern that many
people believe
is just clear right so there
is disproportionate killing of uh black
people by cops
but in absolute terms it more often
happens to
white people and in any case the data is
modeled but that does not mean
that when people who have experienced
brutality um see it on
film that it does not call forth an
honest reflection of some different
experience that they are having with
cops
and so in any case i'm
very troubled that everything gets hung
on a single incident which can then
undercut it if the incident isn't what
it appears to be
i'm more troubled by the
undercutting of the legitimacy of the
initial outpouring of emotion
that came from the looting and the
violence which we have seen so much of
and i am
very interested in us unpacking
how this all works and why this protest
has turned so ugly and so
um uh
cynical i would say i mean just the
simple prevalence
of um
needless beatings and um and
stealing of goods and all really
just makes it uh
it makes it very hard to say anything
nuanced
about it because i feel like there was
something to be said at first and now
those of us who would say it have
found ourselves in the very awkward
position of wanting to be
wanting to be very clear that we don't
support
the wanton destruction i mean
what even is this there's no there are
no demands on the table there's nothing
obvious that could be done to placate
other than signs of
failty which are not even appropriate
well there's a way
you know it is reminiscent of evergreen
in some ways in part because
some of what is happening is coming from
exactly the same playbook
and um you know what one of
one of the things that i am seeing is
a demand for for submission
and a a call for allyship uh
on the part of all those who would join
the cause but uh
don't have the the right skin color
and it's that part is alarming
in its similarity to what we saw
yeah i mean i think uh in the spirit of
history doesn't repeat itself but it
rhymes and as we said as
evergreen was unfolding evergreen was
ahead of the curve
but that given time we would get there
if people didn't take the warning
we have now arrived there the
particulars are different
you know the hazards are different um
evergreen was dangerous and i as
evergreen was unfolding
i had the terrible sense that it was
unfolding that the
uh extraordinary
the exaggerated nature of what we were
seeing
was very much like a sort of poorly
poorly drawn movie everything was so
over the top
that it was it looked like a movie
script in which somebody
didn't have a knack for subtlety and
what i worried about the whole time
was that it was very clear based on the
way movie scripts go
especially one written without subtlety
was that that movie was going to end
with an ironic lynching
of a white person and that the most
likely person for that to be would have
been
me so anyway i was very glad that we
uh i think derailed it i'm not saying
that that would have happened but given
that the violence was escalating and
that the police were out of the picture
that certainly was seemed a possibility
and we are now seeing the same things in
play
in uh you know in the nation as a whole
so one to go back to the first point you
raised with regard to
a difference between what we're seeing
unfold society-wide
uh in in the united states right now
versus what happened at evergreen three
years ago
right now um is that there was you know
george bridges the president of
evergreen was no trump
and never would have aspired to be such
a person and in fact
the uh the epithets that people
came up with for him involved spineless
and invertebrate and beta
and you know this sort of thing right
and i think this actually points out
one of um yeah we we needed
a leader then evergreen needed a leader
and the country needs a leader now
and in either case did we or do we have
a good leader
but the failures are radically different
so george bridges
could not figure out or was not
interested in figuring out how to
actually lead
or how to be actually alpha
which is what we want in a leader so if
if it's okay i know you have
places that you want to go here but can
i just say a few things about what what
an alpha is
because i think this is something that
um
trump imagines he is but
the term comes out of animal behavior
and i've thought a lot about this
ever since uh ever since we were in
college in fact when we were studying
with bob trevors
and beginning to study the evolution of
social behavior and i specifically was
reading the work of franz dewall
who who's an extraordinary primatologist
and his work
um he's written many books um his most
recent one is
mama's last hug which is about um the
evolution and experience of emotion in
non-human animals but at that point i
was reading
peacemaking among primates in service of
my undergraduate senior thesis which was
about
the role of affiliations and friendships
between female non-human primates
and um you know typically in social
species
um that have adult males and adult
females living side by side you have
distinct dominance hierarchies that
there's male dominance hierarchies and
there's female dominance hierarchies and
they
often play by sort of the same rules but
not exactly
and then male female relationships are
not always inherently sexual but there's
different roles there
right so um i was thinking about
peacemaking among primates dewall's book
from must be the 80s
in um in reference to this this presser
that he held yesterday that trump held
yesterday it was so
remarkable uh and you pointed out that
george will
who is you know famously conservative
wrote within i don't know practically
minutes of
that press conference coming out an
op-ed in washington post
in which he said among other things
quote that trump is
a weak person's idea of a strong person
this is one of the most
compelling conservative voices uh that
we we still have
around um you know you and i remember
him from when we were in high school so
this guy's been around for a long time
um dewall makes the argument
in uh in his newest book mama's last hug
that most people have a character in
their heads of what an alpha male
is based in fact in part on the fact
that newt gingrich
in the 90s recommended dewalt's book
chimpanzee politics power and sex among
apes to freshman congressmen in the
early 90s
and that this prompted this caricature
of self-confidence
and swagger and purpose and alphas
beating the hell out of everyone and
reminding every one day who the winner
is
and alpha goes it alone he crushes the
competition um and
alpha's basically like a bully in this
rendering right
and the truth dewall points out in
chimps and he would argue in humans as
well
is that okay some alphas are indeed
merciless tyrants
fair enough the biggest strongest
meanest they have uh
they they are exactly that thing but
they're the exception that
many more alphas that he has seen in his
decades of working
with non-human primates is that alpha
males don't get to the top on their own
they have assistance the smallest you
know the actual physically smallest
male can be alpha if he has the right
supporters
and most alphas protect the underdog
keep the peace reassure those who are
distressed and
for me the most surprising thing here as
someone who has
studied social behavior of animals in
the wild for
also decades is that alphas tend to be
what duvall calls the healer in chief
that he and his his people did an
analysis of consoling behavior
specifically
who gives hugs who offers hugs after
someone has lost a height a fight
and in general females give many more
hugs than males
in chimps in other species but
even though that's true that across the
board females
give more hugs to console losers of
fights
the alpha male is the exception to that
alpha males far and away
give more hugs to those who have lost
fights than
anyone else in the entire system when
fights break out the community looks to
the alpha to see how to handle it
and one last thing dewalt writes quote
he is the final arbiter
intent on restoring harmony he will
impressively stand between screaming
parties with his arms raised
until things calm down that's leadership
i get where you're going with this but i
do not want a hug from that man
um now all right so hey this is really
interesting you and i did not talk about
this beforehand and of course i was on a
parallel track i should just say that
the concept alpha with respect to dogs
is not what people think it is
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about something else
um what the important
uh i i want to actually take issue with
one thing
all right i guess i'm taking issue with
george will here a little bit
george with judge well not franz de waal
right okay which is
that i so the quote that i gave from
george well was uh trump is a weak
person's idea of a strong person is it
that or something else in the end no
that's that
yeah um i think that this is easy to get
wrong trump actually is
strong he has navigated his way to the
top
successfully and i believe he is riding
this
crisis to his own benefit successfully
to all of our great detriment and to
tremendous risk to the republic
but nonetheless there is
power in what he is doing i believe he
has an obligation not to pursue it and
that he falls down on that obligation
quite regularly
what i do think will is alluding to here
is that trump is not a secure man
trump is an insecure man who is
compensating for that insecurity for his
desperate need for affirmation and you
can hear this in so many of the things
that he says where
he's always talking about how great we
are and how we never lose and then i
mean i saw a tweet today in which
you know he he has a parenthetical thank
you trump or something i mean
thank you president trump for some
claimed victory or whatever
the point is it's transparent that he is
insecure
and my feeling is um
as a man who has observed other men over
a long period of time
a powerful insecure man is a very
dangerous phenomenon and at this moment
it could not possibly be more of a
hazard to us
so um he is powerful
he is successful at wielding at
gathering and wielding power
and he is dangerous because the end to
which he will wield it is very
frequently
a self-aggrandizing end when at the you
know what we need of course is a leader
who is uh a patriot and that inherently
means one who
will sacrifice for his nation when
need be which means bypassing political
opportunity
in order to better the nation to heal
the crisis whatever it is so
largely in agreement but um but it is
the insecurity
that i believe is so lethal you i think
you used the word
needy with me a week or two ago you said
i wasn't sure exactly what it was
apropos but this this was beginning to
to boil all of this and you said
i think the trait that i find hardest to
deal with in other people
is neediness and insecurity and
neediness are not identical but they are
certainly closely aligned concepts
well it is particularly bad in a man
whose
signature is strength and power right
because the strength and power gets
wielded in a very dangerous way
um so um
sorry i don't know what power tool that
is that threw me
here indeed um
what did i want to say well i've now
forgotten it but
um okay
let's talk a little bit about the
protests themselves
and how they are interacting with all of
this something that's been on my mind
quite a bit in the last several days
is the tension between a
a peacemaking dynamic that i have seen
hints of many times now
and the thing that disrupts it and what
i want to call
our viewers attention to
is the way game theory haunts this whole
story
so the first thing i want to say is
riots
and looting have a particular nature
to them okay there's a reason that
looting is a thing that has a name
that very frequently emerges in history
at times of crisis and it basically
works like this
if you have a a city
you hire some number of police officers
it has to be enough to do the job
it and then it's a diminishing returns
problem so you could hire
more cops and if you hire more cops it
costs more
and the good you get out of adding
another cop to the force
goes down with each unit above some
level
and so you want to hire an economically
efficient number of cops
and that economically efficient number
of cops is inevitably based on what's
necessary under normal circumstances
there is a point at which your cops
become so busy
with some phenomenon that is unusual
with some kind of
black swan event or something that the
usual force that keeps people in line
that keeps honest people honest
breaks down and those people who are
hovering closest to the edge of that
border
discover that the thing that would
ordinarily penalize them for doing x y
or z
happens to be preoccupied with something
else and so
they engage in looting that is a very
sad but
normal uh phenomenon
the problem here is that it doesn't take
very much to put us in jeopardy of that
and in the context of a protest that
started out over something
legitimate we have the added phenomenon
of let's say that the protest is one
thing it's the george
floyd protest and the george floyd
protest suffers from the fact
that if somebody loots a store in
chicago
it is then seen by everybody everywhere
the protest has now paid the price
of the looting that went on on some
corner
in chicago and that decreases the added
cost
of somebody looting in houston
so in some sense we have a tragedy of
the commons unfolding
where the people who are
[Music]
least in line with the objective of the
protest
begin to to color the way the protest
unfolds
because they do the dramatic thing that
violates
the notion that this is an honest
outgrowth of sentiment
and it spreads because uh as long as the
protest is paying the cost
of uh looking bad uh the opportunity to
get an upgraded phone is irresistible
for a lot of people so
um anyway it's it's a tragedy of the
commons and tragedy is a real tragedy in
this case
[Music]
okay so now let's carry through to the
game theory that we're seeing unfold
that goes the other direction
and we've seen this several times in
portland this week and we've seen it
elsewhere
there's something new and this did not
happen during occupy i have to tell you
i never saw it even once
there's a moment at which the protesters
are calm and the cops are calm
and they are trying to figure out how to
negotiate with each other
right the cops do not like the
predicament where they have to crack
down on the protesters does that mean no
cops like it no
those cops are on the force too but
there are lots of cops who don't want to
be cracking down on people and they're
getting pushed into it and they don't
like it and
anyway it's all understandable so they
want to negotiate too
there's a moment of calm there's some
sort of exchange of
light-heartedness or good will or
something
right and then some [ __ ] lights a
firecracker or throws a bottle or
does something right or an [ __ ] on
the other side decides
to fire some tear gas or whatever it is
and the thing
breaks down in an instant and all it
takes is one
all it takes is one and the point i
think that i'm deriving from this
always annoyed me that occupy thought
that it needed to be a leaderless
movement now it did that for a reason a
movement with leaders can be co-opted or
their leaders can be
killed or disrupted in other ways so
leaders are a vulnerability
but not having them is an even bigger
vulnerability because what it means
is there's nobody in a position to to
calm
the crowd to punish the person who would
set off the firecracker there's nobody
to say
actually that doesn't speak for us
that's right that's not us
right and because that person is absent
there is no mechanism for this natural
peacemaking tendency
to actually take over we could get
somewhere without
trump imposing martial law for god's
sake
we could get there if we had some
mechanism to allow the natural
peacemaking to happen even now
even after all of the looting and
violence that we've seen
yeah if if any group could define
someone
and allow them to speak for the group
there would be fewer bottles thrown at
the point that peace is emerging
the prediction one of the predictions of
what you just laid out
is that
those those things that break an
emerging piece
in standoffs between protesters and
police
are more likely to emerge from the
protesters than from the police because
of course
um the police does have hierarchy does
have leader
and um if if the police department in
question
is not wholly corrupt and i believe
that there are vanishingly few entirely
corrupt police departments in the u.s at
this point
not to say that there might not be some
or that there aren't some with
way higher percentage of corrupt police
than than
i would then i would want to know
um but someone
a a member of the force who does
something wrong as polices emerge as
as pieces emerging uh can be
reprimanded um by their leader and their
leader could say
that doesn't stand for us whereas there
is no mechanism by which that exists
among a literalist hierarchy-less
group of protesters peaceful you know
peaceful until they're not protesters
yeah i agree there's a hierarchy
inherent to the police force which
allows
for control if that's the instinct and
this then gets us to this very thorny
issue
of the anarchists and in particular the
the antifa
although frankly i don't even want to
play that game anymore i guess the
antifa exists
and you know the president has learned
that he can invoke them
and rile people up because they make
themselves
uh so difficult to uh to empathize with
and frankly they make the entire
protest movement so they by design they
make it impossible to empathize with
that's that's their whole mo
um but the the problem here
is that they actually have an ideology
it's goofy as all get out right it would
not take
two hours of careful thought to explain
why it's incorrect and must not be
allowed to drive the movement but you
never get the two hours
right um i must have spent 100 hours
during occupy trying to explain to the
anarchists why this wasn't going to work
for very simple mundane reasons it
didn't have to do with anybody being out
to get them just has to do with
basically whether the strategy they're
advocating is stable
or whether it opens the door to tyranny
um but you never get there which means
that that little ideology which they
get together and discuss privately that
thing
is then allowed to interfere
with the natural tense relationship that
would otherwise exist between the
protesters and the cops
right but the the
ability of a small number of people
to demonize the entire police force so
that the police force
are not people they are vermin and then
the police
see the protesters in the same light and
nobody's allowed to cross the line
because that's considered
treason that thing is what is causing
this tragedy
and um i don't know how i mean
in a in a leaderless movement and this
obviously is a leaderless movement at
the moment
i don't know how it is that somebody
makes the point
generally actually for you
to have your grievance addressed you
have to get away from those people
they are about something else they are
actually about the wrong idea
that if you tear civilization apart what
replaces it will be
better they are wrong about that idea
and they are causing your movement to do
their bidding right that's unacceptable
and you need leaders
to stop it and if you just imagine i
mean i've seen a lot of
comparisons this week of uh the current
situation
with you know 1968 and in particular
but the big difference is the total
leadership vacuum
on all sides there's just no leadership
you've got politics being played at the
top level
you've got a movement in which nobody is
empowered to speak
and you know it's just it's a disaster
in the making well
i mean another key difference and this
is
so obvious it feels like it's not worth
saying but it's utterly critical
is that um you know as you mentioned
earlier someone
loots in chicago and the entire world
sees it so there is no ability for any
of these protests in any of the american
cities to emerge to evolve organically
on their own
we would expect that protests that
happen in portland
versus minneapolis versus dc versus
atlanta
versus la wherever to be different
the people are different even absent
differences in cultures
and geography it's just different human
beings involved and there will be
different initial conditions
and different people making errors and
those errors will be different and
different people making
excellent decisions and those excellent
decisions will be different
what the what social media
and widespread access to the internet
allows
is for a universalizing of experience
and the destruction of individual
cultural and regional differences such
that there is no possibility
for organic
protests to evolve distinctly in any
place
at the point that we started this became
a positive feedback
chaos it was almost impossible that it
could be stopped
unless you know any city that wasn't
already doing that needed to effectively
block itself from being able to see what
was going on in the rest of the world
and we have no mechanism for that
yeah i i started having a thought like
this
when i first saw the um
the footage of nicholas christakis being
confronted at yale right and there was
something so
odd about this because we now know
nicholas
uh personally and he is every bit as
decent as he seems online and
you know in speeches and all and so you
had these very
privileged kids at yale
confronting this very decent person
as a proxy for some battle that if it's
any
anything like evergreen doesn't even
exist at yale right so
at evergreen we had a battle over white
supremacy that didn't exist there
as if it existed there and the whole
thing made no sense because of that
same thing at yale and so what you're
saying and i i see it too
is there is an
honest heartfelt objection to something
but it isn't everywhere and to have that
objection raised
you've got a problem cops and their
enforcement against
citizens is the is the question and you
have
cops confronting citizens over this
question all over the place
irrespective of how those cops are doing
with those citizens and so
it basically takes the problem and it
duplicates it everywhere
even if the problem wasn't so bad in
some places and was really terrible in
other places and
exactly there's there's real grievance
there's real grievance that people have
but what we're seeing is not based on
real grievance
always well i don't even want to say
that it's not it's not always based on
real grievance i'm
certain of that that's not what i mean
of course there is
phony baloney stuff but
let's put it this way i think there was
a conversation to be had
at yale and i think there was a
conversation to be had at evergreen
the thing that made it impossible to
have the conversation was the accusation
that it was present
right there right so in other words my
feeling is
if you maybe you're a black person who
finds yourself
at yale and maybe there isn't racism at
yale in the sense
that they were complaining about but
because you're a privileged member from
that population
in some sense you have a greater
obligation because you have the
opportunity to raise the point that
things are not
generally fair and that lots of people
don't have those opportunities
you feel some lineage-based obligation
to raise the point
because you've made it to a place where
the point can actually be heard
now that doesn't look anything like
shrieking at nicholas christakis no
right that's the opposite of what it
means but
there's no we don't have the proper
tooling to allow somebody to speak
you know for those who aren't in a good
position to do it
without alleging that it is themselves
that they are speaking for
in some sense and so we are seeing the
dynamic unfold and it is
um it is ironic
paradoxical counterproductive
and in the end um
it makes it just makes the point
unhearable
yeah now when i one of one of
the pieces of my 14 point
introduction to today's live stream um
that was just part of one sentence at
the very end i think you know we've
spent a lot of time talking about this
in the past
but i think is actually critical the
fact that we have
drugged a whole generation of people
with
with legal drugs with mood disruptors
mood eveners uh as well as steroid
hormones and
and all sorts of other madness but uh
especially uh especially having
uh drugged children during their
development
who were given
who were given diagnoses of either
having anxiety disorders
or attention deficit hyperactivity
disorders
and they were not allowed to grow up and
to learn how to experience their own
emotional states to understand their own
psychology
at the point that they show up in
college or beyond
they've been in lockdown for a while
they don't see what their prospects are
they don't know how they're gonna get
out from under debt
they don't know how to have health
insurance how to have relationships
and they see something as brutal as a
man
being killed while crying for help under
the knee
of a of a a baby but
a cop of a different race who is white
and it all comes out yeah it all comes
out of course it does
but that doesn't mean that all of the
anger is about
the thing this is not all about
george floyd no i mean george floyd is
uh is the symbol and you know there's
actually a long history of that
with respect to historic protests where
somebody's death
triggers basically you know all of the
pent-up
emotion that comes from all of the
deaths of people whose names we don't
know
so you know anyway that's that's sort of
a natural process
but um
i guess i'm also just struck by
the leadership vacuum is really to me
it's just almost impossible
to get past it at this point and and the
fact that we are hurtling towards an
election that if nothing amazing happens
will result in us uh continuing for
another four years without a leader at
the top
at a moment when we absolutely
positively 100 need one
so that dynamic itself suggests that we
have a whole
second layer of problem that needs
addressing but
in all of this i keep thinking
um with respect
to interesting uh
dynamic heterodox thinkers
no place do we have a deeper bench than
when it comes
to people who are of african descent
in america it's amazing how many high
quality people we have
and they are by and large sidelined from
this discussion it's not to say they
aren't saying things on twitter but
the idea that we are not drafting these
people to center stage to have that
conversation
uh to me is just very odd because
they um
the absence of a martin luther king like
figure here is
a tragedy the fact that we have many
people
who i believe many of them could play
some role like that but combined there's
no
question the fire power is there to move
this discussion
so you're thinking about just i i did
not know you're going to say this but
just off the top of my head
let's see uh john mcwhorter glenn lowry
coleman hughes chloe valderry john wood
jr
bob woodson more more more more
josephine mathias she's canadian
oh well all right we annex canada
we get josephine yeah um let's see who
have we forgotten
um many i'm sure but yeah but i mean
even even just there
um that's a that's an incredibly large
uh riley
jason riley not sure okay
um in any case uh you got uh thomas
chatterton williams on your list no
okay yeah so this is not not in america
now but he's an american living in
france
so this is a lot of people who uh deeply
understand stuff and um
you know i'm i'm now regularly asked by
people
well if you were in trump's shoes what
would you do and i resent the question
because i never would have let it got
this
to this spot right i would have um
done much more much sooner and frankly
it's hard to imagine botching the job
this badly
but one of the things that i certainly
would have done had i found myself in
that position
was i would have brought all of those
people in and we would have been having
a very deep conversation about what the
state of race relations are in the u.s
especially with respect
to black and white dynamics and you know
how do i know that's what i would have
done because you and i proposed this
very thing whenever green came apart
before they forced us out
our proposal was to bring many of those
people together for a conference on race
relations
to turn evergreen around to take that
absurd spectacle of a meltdown
and turn it into something positive that
would change the national conversation
and they said no and they said no of
course because that's the evergreen way
yeah so we're nearing the end of an hour
um
i want to finish with a little
dostoevsky but i know you have some
other things that you want to talk about
here i have a couple things that i have
to so we'll return to dostoyevsky
i promised on twitter
to explain why i disliked the atlantic
article which
you have a link to um it was an atlantic
article
is it this yes and it says
the protests will spread the coronavirus
um and i had an immediate negative
reaction to this because although there
is positive stuff in this article
that title specifically is very
misleading
and it is misleading for reasons that
people who have been watching this
podcast will
intuit one thing is
we do not know if the coronavirus is
going to be spread by the protest
there's one reason to think that that is
actually not highly likely
and that is that the coronavirus there
is substantial evidence
to suggest it is very difficult to
contract outdoors
now the article does go to great lengths
to say
not great length but it goes to some
lengths to say that
arrests actually that put people in
paddy wagons and cells are there for
a particular liability but
my concern is there is almost certain to
be
a jump in the number of cases because
the lockdown is being eased that
jump is going to be attributed to the
protest which is then going to be blamed
on the protesters which is unfair
now if we can begin to segue to the next
little piece of this puzzle
it's possible that the protest will
spread the virus i would advise
everybody who is out there a you should
probably figure out what to do about the
riot problem and until you do you should
go home
but you should wear a mask
but one of the things we don't know is
whether outdoors
is comparatively safe because of uv
light in which case
night time will not have that effect and
they should be
very very careful or
if it is something else like the high
volume of the spaces and there's a lot
of evidence that circumstantially
suggests that that will be the case
because
uh the movement of air seems to be uh
contributing to
safety and all i've seen evidence that
it's that it's both and perhaps more but
that
that absent uv light at night there will
be less protective effect of being
outside but there is still protective
effect of having
open space and uh dispersion of
viral particles right okay so i said
something very provocative
on twitter which was that's actually the
coronavirus
this other thing you sent no no the
the protest could be protective because
a lot of people who would otherwise be
indoors during the lockdown will be
outdoors where it's very difficult to
control
okay i mean i'm not i'm just saying
that's a possibility so
that could be protective but what i
don't want to see is us leap to the
conclusion when we do see a jump in the
number of cases which is almost certain
based on the end of the lockdown that it
was the protest that did it that's
unfair to the protesters and
it treads very close to a recurrent
trope in history
where the enemy is declared to be
something like
infectious right so anyway i don't want
to see that happen
all right a couple other points
on coronavirus one i don't have a link
for this one
but evidence uh started to emerge
this week of it being a primarily
uh circulatory blood blood vessel-borne
virus which is both curious
and interacts with the lab origin
hypothesis
potentially because one of the possible
techniques that might have been used in
a laboratory if this
did in fact emerge from a laboratory
would have involved passage through what
are called hela cells now hela cells
are a very famous cell line from human
beings a cell line that has been in
circulation for many decades
and the reason that you can have a cell
this is the henrietta lacks
um so there was a movie made about her
recently this whole story i don't
remember exactly what but this is the
gila being
henrietta lacks cell so it's her line
it's her cell line now
if you're paying real close attention to
the podcast you'll think how could you
have a cell line circulating
for decades wouldn't it have run out of
telomere
right well what kind of cell doesn't run
out of telomere cancer cells don't
helen lacks died of cancer and these
henrietta lacks
died of cancer and these cells are
cells from her tumor which now vastly
outnumbers i understand it the number of
cells that were in her body when she was
alive
and they are used as human model cells
in many laboratory experiments
so cancers have an interesting dynamic
cancers that actually function and are
persistent have an interesting dynamic
with respect to blood vessels they have
to grow them
in order to feed that mass of tissue
which is growing and
doesn't have access to the circulatory
system of the body so it would die off
it would get necrotic and die off
if it didn't generate its own
circulatory vessel so one question is
if this was created with a laboratory
serial passage experiment in something
like hela cells
would it have a unique relationship to
blood vessels i don't know
but it's certainly something we would
want to study and ruling out the
possibility that it came through a lab
will prevent us from doing so which
brings me
to the next point so i've
told viewers of this podcast that the
laboratory
origin hypothesis and by laboratory
origin i don't mean that the thing was
created fully in a lab i mean that a lab
would have taken
a virus from the wild and might have
made a chimera or it might have put it
through serial passage or it might have
done both
and in so doing modified what the virus
does
and then the virus might have escaped or
it could just have been brought into the
lab and could have escaped
from the lab without modification but
that the viability of those hypotheses
is greatly much greater than what we are
being led to believe
by establishment sources
and that we are effectively being misled
that
any such idea is uh preposterous from a
scientific point of view which is of
course not
correct well that narrative
that those who talk about this idea are
obviously not
grasping the science that narrative has
begun
to crack it began to crack in a major
way
with an article by matt ridley in the
washington post
earlier this week so that's this suck if
you want to put that up
here's matt ridley the article is short
but excellent and it points out that the
laboratory
hypothesis is anything but dead and that
the wuhan
fish market hypothesis is effectively
dead
and then there's this more recently a
much more extensive
article in the independent science news
that argues that in fact the laboratory
origin hypothesis
is most probable which is of course the
position that i took weeks ago on this
podcast these are both worth reading
they both reference yuri deegan's work
who we looked at
in an earlier live stream and in any
case
the point here is not that we know that
this came from the lab we still don't
know and none of these authors would say
so
right but what we do know is that
anybody who was telling you from the
beginning that that was a non-viable
hypothesis
was misleading you and we now have a
terrible problem as i warned you we
would
and that terrible problem is that such a
large fraction like nearly a hundred
percent of the virology community
has been backing this story that
laboratory origin
was a dead-on arrival hypothesis that
now we have no experts we can go to
almost that's an amazing predicament to
be in in light of the
sars cove ii predicament that we find
ourselves in
so in any case that's more or less where
things stand
i would argue we have an obligation to
take this hypothesis seriously because
this is where the evolutionary dynamics
come in if it did come through the lab
it will have been modified to laboratory
conditions
that could provide us opportunities to
fight it and it could provide
obstacles that we need to know about and
if we don't take this hypothesis
seriously at the highest level
we're not going to figure it out and the
opportunities are going to pass us by
and we're going to fall right into the
hazards
all right you want to go to dostoyevsky
yeah before we
before we break yep yeah so um
to finish up the idea of the plague that
we are experiencing being not just the
pathogen but also the
the societal collapse that accompanies
uh
the pathogen either before or after uh
was an idea that
showed up for me formally this week on
twitter um
an account at mimetic value
said by the way when modern narrative
problems that people focus
too much on the virus it's true that the
virus causes the disease but this focus
leads us to missing the whole picture
continues traditionally before the
pathogen origin of diseases were
discovered people associate the whole
time period of chaos with the plague
the social contagion of the virus of the
riots is intertwined with the biological
contagion of the virus together they are
the plague
so i found this fascinating and asked
this uh this
person i'm imagining a he i don't i
don't know um
if he had a reference and he pointed me
to a rene gerard
paper from 1974 called the plague in
literature and myth
in which gerard cites um
shakespeare and dostoevsky and many
others and specifically
he cites the very last bits of
of crime and punishment of fiero
dostoevsky's
18 what is it 66 novel
um with as is so typical of dostoyevsky
a really
complicated and um you know difficult
and yet
ultimately endearing protagonist
raskolnikov
so in the very last pages of crime and
punishment raskolnikov reports a dream
and i just want to finish with uh with
this directly from dostoevsky in the
in the um translation of course
he dreamt that the whole world was
condemned to a terrible new strange
plague that had come to europe from the
depths of asia
some new sorts of microbes were
attacking the bodies of men but these
microbes were endowed with intelligence
and will
men attacked by them became at once mad
and furious
but never had men considered themselves
so intellectual and so completely in
possession of the truth as these
sufferers
never had they considered their
decisions their scientific conclusions
their moral convictions so infallible
whole villages whole towns and peoples
went mad from the infection
all were excited and did not understand
one another
each thought that he alone had the truth
and was wretched looking at the others
beat himself on the breast wept and rung
his hands
they did not know how to judge and could
not agree what to consider evil and what
good
they did not know whom to blame whom to
justify
men killed each other in a sort of
senseless spite
they gathered together in armies against
one another but even on the march the
arms would begin attacking each other
their ranks would be broken and the
soldiers would fall on each other
stabbing and cutting
biting and devouring each other the
alarm bell was ringing all day long in
the towns
men rushed together but why they were
summoned and who was summoning them
no one knew the most ordinary trades
were abandoned because everyone proposed
his own ideas
his own improvements and they could not
agree the land too was abandoned
men met in groups agreed on something
swore to keep together but it once began
on something quite different from what
they had proposed
they accused one another fought and
killed each other there were
conflagrations and famine
all men and things were involved in
destruction the plague spread
and moved further and further
that's dusty ask you from 1866. wow um
yeah and in fact uh 1866 1866
okay so just barely post origin of
species
but there is something to this notion of
rotten ideas and their spread and uh
viruses which spread differently but in
a parallel fashion
and we are seeing and end up intertwined
in
an inseparable way in an inseparable way
yeah i am put in mind
of the president's remarkable
speech and then yesterday's photo op
stunt last evening
and thinking that he strikes me very
much
as a man who believes his ideas to be so
correct
that they are not worth
putting through any kind of challenge
it's a very frightening situation we
find ourselves in
it is yes um
all right um i think we have reached the
end of this
hour we will take a 15-minute break
and we will see you at uh
on the do are we going to continue with
this link zach or are we going to give
them a new link
[Music]
okay new link in the description see you
in 15 minutes
and we look forward to answering your
questions
you